SPEAKER: Well, to everyone
here in Mountain View,
welcome, good afternoon.
For the Googlers tuning in
around the world, good morning,
good evening to you as well.
We're in for a treat today.
We're here with Erik Larson.
Erik, thinks for being here.
ERIK LARSON: Thank
you very much.
Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER: So Erik, as
you all probably know,
is the author of a number
of bestselling books.
Some really great ones,
"Devil in the White City,"
"Thunderstruck," "In
the Garden of Beasts."
And his latest book,
which we're here
to talk about
today, "Dead Wake -
The Last Crossing
of the Lusitania"
is now number one on "The New
York Times" Best Sellers list.
We've got some prepared Q&A.
We'll take some time, maybe
halfway through, half an hour
in, and take some audience
questions.
I'm sure you have
many, out there.
And we're good to go.
I'll begin with a
general one, Erik.
So what's the process
you go through
to pick your subject
material, and
how did you stumble
across the "Lusitania?"
ERIK LARSON: The processes
is generally, stumbling.
Yeah.
The "Lusitania" came about
in sort of an unusual way,
because it's not
the kind of thing
that I might
typically want to do.
I like an idea that
has-- what, when
I used to work for "The
Wall Street Journal,"
we referred to as--
barriers to entry.
That is to say competitive.
Something that would
make it less likely
that somebody else
would do the same book.
Like "Devil in the White City"
or my book "Thunderstruck"
about Marconi and
Crippen, and so forth.
But I'd always been
interested in the "Lusitania."
I'd always been interested
maritime history.
Frankly, I would have done
a book about the "Titanic"
if it hadn't been done to death
by James Cameron and Celine
Dion.
You know?
But it just seemed, at first,
too obvious, too familiar.
Until I just-- I really had
nothing else on my plate,
so I started reading about it.
I was aware that in
five years-- this
goes back to five years ago--
I was aware that in five years
there would be the
100th anniversary.
I don't usually
like to peg things
to anniversaries,
because I don't think
anybody particularly cares.
And it also
practically guarantees
that somebody else is going
to be doing the same book.
But, as a former journalist,
it gave me a reason
for doing it, like, now.
Why do it today?
And that quieted
that voice, so--
SPEAKER: I see.
Wonderful.
You alluded to a question
I was going to ask later,
but now is a good time.
Why has the "Lusitania"
not received
the same intrigue as
something like the "Titanic?"
ERIK LARSON: Leo DiCaprio.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's interesting.
I think, frankly, a lot of it
does have to do with the fact
the "Titanic" predated
the "Lusitania."
And the "Titanic" was
so full of glamour,
and pathos, and
sank in three hours
with not enough
lifeboats, the whole saga.
Maybe if the "Titanic"
had never sunk,
the "Lusitania" might be
a more prominent thing
in people's eyes.
But I think another factor is
that we're all taught-- well,
I can't speak for
everybody here--
but I know I was taught
about the "Lusitania"
strictly in passing.
In a European survey
history course,
where the "Lusitania" was that
was a dusty geopolitical node
on the timeline heading
toward World War I.
And nobody ever really got
into the details of the thing.
It was when I started
reading some of the details
about the actual sinking,
that's what really hooked me.
For example, one of the
first things that kind of
lit my imagination, was when I
learned that during the sinking
itself, one fully
loaded lifeboat fell
on top of another
fully loaded lifeboat.
That was kind of, whoa, I
never knew any of that stuff.
Or that three
passengers were sucked
into one of the gigantic
funnels during the sinking,
and then were blown out
again, alive and well.
You know, covered with
soot, but-- so there
were all these little details.
That's what made me
think, I'm going to write
about the sinking, itself.
SPEAKER: Wonderful.
I think the context of
these passengers knowing
about the "Titanic" disaster
just three years prior,
that actually sets up the
first theme I'd like to chat
about today, which is intel.
Both of the passengers
and crew that
are heading out on the
"Lusitania," but then also
the folks in Britain and around
the world who are monitoring
what Germany's doing.
ERIK LARSON: Right.
SPEAKER: So we'll talk
about the passengers first.
The morning, May 1, 1915, that
the ship is to depart New York.
Can you talk to us about
the ads that are taken out
in the newspapers?
ERIK LARSON: Yeah.
So this was May 1, 1915.
It's a Saturday morning.
And in the newspapers
in New York
that morning, there was an
advertisement-- actually, it's
called a notice, or a warning--
from the German Embassy,
aimed at anybody
who was going to be
traveling into the so-called war
zone around the British Isles.
It was not aimed specifically
at the "Lusitania,"
and frankly, it was in there
that day strictly by chance.
One of the many
weird chance things
that happened in association
with the "Lusitania."
But it essentially reiterated
that there was this war zone,
and if you were going to
sail to the United Kingdom,
you did so at your own risk.
Now, in "The New
York World" this ad
was right next to Cunard's
add for the "Lusitania."
And elsewhere around
the country it
was interpreted that the ad
was aimed at the "Lusitania."
It was not, but that was
how it was perceived.
And yet 2,000 people got
on that ship that day.
You know?
And only like, two or
three people canceled.
Now, if it were me, and
somebody said that, you know,
you're going to fly from here
to London at your own risk,
I'd be off that plane so fast.
You know?
SPEAKER: Right.
Well, that's actually the
heart of the question.
Why do these people
get on board?
There's a great
quote, and forgive me,
I don't have it in front of me.
Somebody describes how the
entire voyage, the passengers
are thinking torpedo.
Eating torpedo--
ERIK LARSON: Thinking,
eating, and dreaming
submarines and torpedoes.
SPEAKER: Yes.
ERIK LARSON: Yeah.
Yeah, but that
was one passenger.
I don't know that
that was commonplace
among the passengers.
I think one of the
things that I find
when doing this kind of
history, and it's referred to
as narrative nonfiction.
I don't particularly
like that label,
but one of the things that I
have found in doing my books
is that it is very important
to put yourself back
into the point of
view of the era.
PoV as screenwriters
like to call it.
And so you can't look back
and say, what on earth
were those people thinking?
Why did they get on that ship?
You can't do it.
You have put yourself in
the mind of the passengers
back then.
And what was going on then,
really, was first of all,
there was this belief that
the "Lusitania" was too big.
Now this may sound familiar
in terms of banks--
it was too big and too fast
to be caught by a submarine.
There was also the prevailing
and pervasive belief
that the rules of
maritime warfare
forbade any sort of attack
on a civilian liner.
Which was, in fact, the case
for the prior 100 years.
But what nobody really
realized, even yet,
was that the rules were
changing very, very quickly
because the submarine.
And then further,
one other component
was, that Cunard was assuring
people that by the time
the ship entered the
so-called war zone,
it would be under the
protection of the Royal Navy.
Which turned out
not to be the case.
SPEAKER: Sure.
A wonderful illusion,
speaking of rules
of maritime engagement,
it's all changing
with U-boats and submarines.
Can you talk to
us about Room 40?
ERIK LARSON: Yeah,
Room 40 was one
of the things that
really surprised me
as I got into the research.
Room 40 was this top,
top, ultra-secret entity
within the Admiralty in Britain,
that was set up very early
in the war to take advantage of
three nearly miraculous events.
And that was the
acquisition, in short order,
by British intelligence, of the
German Navy's-- and actually,
the German diplomatic
side of things, as well--
the three most important
codebooks that the Germans had.
And their acquisition of
these codebooks was secret.
The Germans had no idea.
And Churchill and company, a
handful of others, the secret
was restricted to a
handful of people.
Churchill felt that
these codebooks could
be used to great advantage.
This establishment,
Room 40, named
after the room in the Admiralty
Building, the Old Admiralty
Building in London.
Their job was to take wireless
messages from the German
Navy that had been intercepted,
decode and decipher them.
And in so doing, they
became actually very adept.
They were reading just
about every German Naval
communication throughout
most of the war,
through this entity, Room 40.
SPEAKER: OK, so what did they
know as the "Lusitania" was
actually making the voyage?
Things are changing out
there in the war zone.
What did Room 40 learn about?
ERIK LARSON: Room 40 knew
a lot about the submarine
that ultimately sank
the "Lusitania."
The submarine was U-20, under
the command of one Captain
Walther Schwieger.
And what Room 40 knew
was, first of all
they knew exactly
what his orders were.
And they were not to
sink the "Lusitania,"
they were to sink
any large troop
transport that he encountered.
They knew what his orders were.
They knew exactly what time
that day he left Germany.
They knew his exact course
for the first 24 hours,
because his radio man sent
position reports back to base,
as a sort of way of
testing reach and range
of the wireless apparatus
on the submarine.
So in that first 24
hours, they knew exactly,
as if using a sexton,
knew exactly where
the submarine was.
Most important, they knew,
because of intercepts,
exactly where U-20 was supposed
to set up its patrol, which
was right off Liverpool.
Right in the path where all
the Cunard ships come and go.
Where many, many other ships,
cargo and otherwise, passed.
SPEAKER: OK.
And do they follow
what U-20 does?
There's other vessels that are
coming before the "Lusitania."
Does the threat change at all?
ERIK LARSON: Well, what happens
is, you know, at some point,
inevitably, U-20 lost radio--
lost wireless contact,
there was no voice radio at that
point-- lost wireless contact
with its home base.
And therefore Room 40
had nothing to intercept.
But the presumption
was that it should
have been, that U-20
was still moving down
the far side of the Irish
coast toward its patrol zone.
But then came the two
days before, well, the day
before the actual sinking.
The 24 hour to 48 hour
period where U-20 made itself
known in a very, very
dramatic way, sinking
three ships in short order.
SPEAKER: OK.
And I think that's the heart
of what my question has been,
after reading the book.
You also refer to Churchill.
I think he'd written a letter
where he'd said that as Germany
talked about this war zone--
ERIK LARSON: Well, this
is early in the war.
I think you're talking
about the letter he
wrote to the Board of Trade.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ERIK LARSON: Where he says--
it's very interesting,
what he wrote.
And it has a
subsequent resonance
that's very compelling.
He's writing about how
important it was-- you know,
Britain being, of
course, an island nation,
they needed all the supplies
they could get by sea.
And he was writing
about how important
it was that Britain get as
much traffic-- merchant marine
traffic, cargo ships,
civilian ships--
from America as possible.
And then comes the very telling
paragraph where he says,
and if any of that shipping gets
into trouble, all the better.
All the better.
SPEAKER: And this is
before the "Lusitania" is--
ERIK LARSON: This is well
before the "Lusitania," yeah.
SPEAKER: You fall short,
in the book, I think,
of calling it an
all-out conspiracy.
And I wonder why.
ERIK LARSON: I didn't
have the material
to call it a
conspiracy, so I hang it
on a prominent British
naval historian who
does call it a conspiracy.
And he actually had a change
of heart, frankly, early on.
This historian-- who in
fact was a former member
of British Naval Intelligence.
Early on, he had said in a
book that sort of glancingly
dealt with it, he
said that the failure
to do more with the intelligence
with regard to the "Lusitania"
was, as he put it, a
monumental cock up.
But then later in
life, as more evidence
emerged, in an
interview that is now
on file in the Imperial
War Museum in London,
something very telling.
He says, you know,
as much as I love--
this is him speaking-- he says,
as much as I love the Royal
Navy, he says, I've come to
feel that there was a plot.
I don't know where it came from.
I don't know who was
the originator, he says,
but there had to be a plot.
Then he says, if there
wasn't, would somebody
please tell me otherwise?
So I hang it on him, because
there is no smoking memo.
However, there is
this accumulation
of really interesting evidence
about-- the "Lusitania"
was essentially left
completely unprotected.
Even though everybody
knew this ship was coming.
It was foremost in the, sort
of, thinking of the world,
if you will.
Because of the warning
placed in the papers.
Because of a variety of things.
And here it was left
completely unprotected.
There's so much
evidence on one side,
saying this might
have been deliberate.
But if you were to try to use
this evidence in a court of law
to prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt that that was, in fact,
a conspiracy, you couldn't.
You couldn't.
However, if you do the Newell
hypothesis, what scientists,
you know, when you're
trying to prove something
by disproving it.
If you try to take the
same body of information
and prove that there
was not a conspiracy,
you can't do that either.
SPEAKER: I see.
ERIK LARSON: Can't
do that either.
SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Thank you for--
ERIK LARSON: But the
thing that remains though,
is that for whatever
reason, on that May 7, 1915,
this "Lusitania,"
packed with passengers,
with everybody aware that
this ship was coming,
with vast amounts of information
in the hands of the Admiralty,
nothing was done to protect it.
SPEAKER: Would you go into
why that might have been?
ERIK LARSON: I wish I knew why.
I wish I knew why.
That's one of the
enduring secrets.
The captain of the ship
was never told about U-20.
About U-20's expected
arrival off Liverpool.
He was never told that
nightly, at midnight,
the big German
transmitter at Norddeich
routinely broadcast the comings
and goings of the "Lusitania"
and sister ships from Cunard.
Nor was the captain
even informed
of the three sinkings that
had occurred in short order
before his ship was attacked.
Information that, by then, had
already been in the newspapers
in Liverpool.
In the morning newspapers.
And when the chairman of
the Cunard Steamship Company
was having breakfast
the morning of Friday,
May 7, he read in the newspapers
about these other ships.
And instantly stops
having breakfast,
goes to the Office of the Chief
Naval Officer in Liverpool
and says, look, you've
got to do something.
The "Lusitania" is coming.
You've got to warn them.
You know?
And then there was a very
sort of generic, pale thing
sent to Turner, but nothing
that at all described
the true danger the
captain was facing.
SPEAKER: Enduring mystery.
ERIK LARSON: Enduring mystery.
And it's not that,
frankly, it's not
that huge a part of the book.
The book, really,
the point of the book
is to really try to bring
to life the human dimension
of the thing.
I mean, the thing
that, in addition
to just the details, that
kind of lit my imagination.
The thing also, was, that
drew me to the project,
was that in my first
exploratory visit to an archive.
Which, actually, was down
here at Stanford University,
at the Hoover Institution.
I became aware-- they have a
modest "Lusitania" collection.
There are vast resources in
the United Kingdom, which
I tapped for this book, but
very early on in the process,
it gave me a sense of
something that I had not
I had any of my previous books.
And that was the
depth, and richness,
and texture of the
material available
about the "Lusitania,"
seemed to offer me
a whole new opportunity
to tell the story.
To essentially put on
my Alfred Hitchcock hat,
and tell the story in as
suspenseful a way as possible.
In a way that would
put us, hopefully,
readers on the ship, and
experience what the people
there were experiencing.
But with, and I guess it's sort
of hard to convey it, but just
the texture of the material.
From telegrams, to the war log
of the submarine commander,
which was eventually found
and translated by German Naval
Intelligence, which tells
exactly what happened
in that entire dismal patrol
that that submarine commander
took, from the day he
left Germany, to the day
he came back.
Including narrative
passages about being chased
by destroyers, horrible
weather, failed
torpedoes, the whole deal.
And so all this stuff
taught me that I
could tell this story
in a very different way.
And that's the thing that made
me finally pull that trigger.
SPEAKER: Wonderful.
I probably couldn't have asked
for a more perfect transition
to the second of two themes
I kind of wanted to cover,
which are the characters.
Now, this is obviously
not a work of fiction,
but I found virtually
every character
that you dive into,
to be so complex.
So human.
I don't want to
steal your thunder,
but I want to just briefly share
the two favorites that I had.
And we will talk a little bit
about the Captain and Commander
of U-boat 20, and
the "Lusitania."
But before them, The first
is a certain Dwight Harris.
So Dwight is leaving New York.
And, I guess, compared
to the other passengers
who just seem to be
getting on the ship,
he seems a little cautious.
A little hesitant.
And so before the
voyage, he goes and buys
a personal custom Wanamaker
life belt for himself.
Which, to me, seems akin
to getting a personal life
preserver before I
hop onto an airplane.
ERIK LARSON: It was.
It was, yeah.
SPEAKER: So he gets on the ship.
And even as he gets
on, he's thinking.
He's analyzing.
He decides, if this
thing is going down,
the departing the
ship at the bow.
And sure enough,
after the attack,
he thinks, do I have time to
go get my custom Wanamaker
lifebelt?
Nope.
OK, I'm going to go jump.
He goes a couple decks
down, he's about to-- oh,
and before he
jumps, he's offered
to enter a lifeboat
that's half empty,
but he thinks, no,
those are going
to be some really in demand
spots in the lifeboat,
I'm going to jump.
Sees the water.
Says, I'd better
get my lifebelt.
Goes and gets his lifebelt.
And then he hangs over
the rail of the ship
and waits for the water
to catch up to his feet,
and dives into the ocean.
Now you do a wonderful job.
We leave him for a moment.
We talk about other people.
The next time we see
our friend Dwight,
he is passing by
a lifeboat that's
empty except for two crewmen,
I believe, who were on board.
ERIK LARSON: Right.
SPEAKER: Something like six
out of all the lifeboats
actually make it into the water.
If you find a lifeboat with
only two crew professionals
on board, you get in.
And he waves them off
and goes for a swim.
ERIK LARSON: Right,
right, right.
Well, now I'm not going to
reveal any more about Dwight
Harris, because I don't
want to give it all away,
but Dwight Harris was, in
fact, my favorite character.
For the main reason being
that, well, first of all,
I love the fact that
he was thinking ahead,
and went shopping for
his own life preserver.
I thought that was very cool.
But what I really liked
about Dwight Harris,
was the fact that in
this lengthy letter
that-- the reason we know about
all this, about Dwight Harris,
is because he wrote a very long,
very good letter to his mother
afterwards.
Anybody who's in this
book, by the way,
is in there because they left
a very detailed record somehow.
But what I love
most about Dwight,
you know, he's on his way,
he's got his engagement ring,
he's going to get
married in England,
or at least ask his
girlfriend to get married.
But he's just so full of
enthusiasm in this letter,
having survived this disaster.
I mean, every other sentence
has multiple exclamation points.
So enthusiastic, not
just of having survived,
but also having been a big
part of this-- not a big part--
of having been part of this
immense historical disaster.
So that's why I just love--
he had to be in the book.
And he's not even the
most prominent character.
SPEAKER: No, he's a minor
character, relatively.
He's your favorite.
Is he the one you
most identified with?
ERIK LARSON: Most
identified with?
I don't know who identified
with most, frankly.
I can't say that really
identified with him.
I can't say that I really
identify with anybody,
except maybe the
submarine commander.
Shouldn't?
I mean, yeah.
I mean the commander,
we were going
to talk about that
a little bit later.
I don't want to jump the
gun, but maybe I will anyway.
But you know, the thing about
the submarine commander--
SPEAKER: That's a
wonderful transition.
Yeah, please, yeah.
ERIK LARSON: That was one
of the surprises to me.
You know, when I got into
this book I was thinking,
god, you know, I sure hope
this guy has, like a huge scar
on his face and wears a
monocle and the whole deal.
Right?
But no.
I mean, this guy was
a 30-year-old guy,
handsome, blue eyes,
charismatic, charming.
The kind of guy you'd want to
go out and get a beer with.
You know?
And his crew loved him.
One time he had six dachshunds
aboard his submarine.
Two parents and four puppies.
And his crew loved him.
A fellow commander said
of him, after the war,
said he couldn't hurt a fly.
Couldn't hurt a fly.
You know, history kind
of proves the opposite.
But I really kind
of-- I can't say
that I identified with the
submarine commander-- that
would be an awful thing to
have stamped on my resume--
but he was a surprisingly
compelling and sympathetic
character.
And I'm a little
troubled by the fact
that-- am I allowed
to mention Twitter?
I'm a little
troubled by the fact
that now that I'm on
Twitter, and I hear things
from readers-- often things
I don't want to hear--
but I hear things from readers.
And one of the things that
I find very fascinating
is that quite a few have
told me that as they're
reading the book, they
find themselves rooting
for the submarine commander.
That's kind of appalling.
But maybe understanding, also.
SPEAKER: Thank you for
sharing that context.
I think prior to, I think,
day three of U-20's mission,
we get that sense of Schwieger.
He takes the submarine to
the bottom on Christmas Day
so they can have
a big music party.
Yeah, he rescues the dogs from
another vessel that he sinks.
One that struck me, is he saw
a horse jumping into the ocean,
after sinking a vessel,
and he orders a dive,
stops looking at the
periscope, because he
couldn't bear to watch.
ERIK LARSON: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Things changed
for me on day three, where,
I think, the first boat he comes
across, I think it has sails.
There's like six men on board.
It's a fishing vessel.
ERIK LARSON: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Why is he
sinking these boats?
ERIK LARSON: Well, you know,
it's all about tonnage.
SPEAKER: That's true.
ERIK LARSON: It was
a game of tonnage.
It didn't matter what you sank,
the point was to sink things.
And among the German
submarine commanders,
the point was to accumulate
as much tonnage as possible.
That was the way
you got to the point
where you would be
considered a submarine ace,
and receive your reward.
Your honors.
And so it didn't matter.
It didn't matter.
Now, he would have preferred
to sink something much larger.
And it was also,
actually, smaller vessels
allowed him to use
his deck gun, which
was his preferred
method of sinking ships
below a certain size, because
the deck gun was reliable.
He had, like 300 shells in
his armory on the submarine.
The deck gun-- his gunnery crew
was deadly accurate and fast.
And so he knew he had
a lot of assurance
that when they fired a shell,
it would strike and blow up.
He did not have that
assurance with torpedoes.
The German Navy
did its own tally,
and found that 60%
of torpedo firings
failed for one
reason or another.
And Schwieger himself
had that experience
on this patrol, which makes it
actually even more remarkable
that he actually did manage
to sink the "Lusitania."
SPEAKER: He's
conflicting character,
or conflicted character.
ERIK LARSON: He wasn't
conflicted, but he's nuanced.
He's nuanced.
SPEAKER: He is.
ERIK LARSON: Let's say that.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
There's more-- I don't
want to give too much away,
I'm sure you don't either.
One more thing on
U-20 and the crew,
one more character I'm
going to highlight,
is a squat fishermen with a
giant flaring red beard who
was a great accordion player.
He looked like a gnome,
could neither read nor write,
but apparently had an
appeal to the opposite sex,
because Schwieger gets multiple
letters from different women
saying, let this guy come home.
I have to marry him.
ERIK LARSON: Right, right.
SPEAKER: What made you want
to explore the U-20 crew
and talk about
their [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK LARSON: Oh, it's
just part of the story.
Once I realized the detail
that was in the submarine's war
log, this chronicle
of its entire journey,
I knew immediately what
the structure of the book
was going to be.
It was going to
be the convergence
of the ship and the submarine.
I mean, that's the logical
suspenseful convergence.
And so, you know, the context
was very, very important.
You had to get to know
some of the crew-- I mean,
to the extent that you can.
I mean, the record of who
was aboard was not that rich.
But there are
accounts available.
And there are people who were
interviewed after the war.
And so, you know,
I felt it was just
absolutely necessary to have
a good sense of what life
was like aboard that submarine.
You know?
SPEAKER: I do.
And speaking of which, the whole
time I'm reading about the set
up this U-boat, and
I'm hearing about
these primitive submarines.
The U-boat sweat.
Do you want to talk
about U-boat sweat?
ERIK LARSON: Well, U-boat
sweat was, like this,
because of condensate on
the walls of the interior
of the submarine.
And whenever it was underwater,
it would get extremely warm.
And it was just like
this oily moist thing
dripping into your coffee.
And you're just living in this
miasma of heat and diesel oil
and moisture.
And then, of course,
you add to that
the fact that there was only
one lavatory, which did not
have very good ventilation.
Then you add 36 guys wearing
leather seasuits day in,
day out.
Never changing, because
what was the point?
They had to be ready at a
moment's notice to get up.
That was, really, just sort of,
to me, it was like, oh my god,
what a horror.
And yet, it was one of
the most coveted things
for young German Naval
officers, sailors to do,
was to join the
submarine service.
Because you were
assured of action.
And the other thing that
kind of surprised me
about the submarines--
these German
submarines-- they
weren't particularly
good at being underwater.
They could only stay under
a relatively brief time.
They traveled very slowly
when underwater-- nine knots
was their maximum speed.
And in fact, when Schwieger
was chased by destroyers,
he came very near to having to
surface-- which would have been
almost certain death-- because
he'd stayed underwater to long,
his batteries were crackling.
And he would have been
blown out of the water
by those destroyers.
Because as accurate as
his own gunners were,
the British Naval gunners
on destroyers were amazing.
They could blow a submarine out
of the water from a mile away.
SPEAKER: I think you
answered the question
that I was getting to, which
was, why would anybody want
to be a submariner at the time?
I mean, we even didn't
talk about U-boat baptisms,
and whatnot.
I don't know if
you want to say--
ERIK LARSON: Well,
it's up to you.
What kind of audience are
we talking about here?
SPEAKER: I think it's a pretty--
ERIK LARSON: A
U-boat baptism was
when you, on a U-boat, if you
flushed the john, essentially,
at a point where the pressure
was it was too high below,
you got a face full of what you
just deposited in that john.
And it was called a U-boat
baptism for naive officers
who were new to a submarine.
SPEAKER: And so is that--
is it the prestige?
Is it the guarantee
of seeing action
that's what drives these men?
ERIK LARSON: Yeah, is was the
guarantee of seeing action.
It was being seen to be heroic.
But mostly is was the action.
It was strange, the members
of the actual surface fleet--
as mighty as the
German surface fleet
was-- the German Navy,
for the most part,
kept that fleet in port.
And it became sort of a
subject of some mockery
within the Germany
Navy, especially
on the part of submariners,
about keeping the fleet safe
for-- you know.
So yeah, the submarine was
a very appealing place,
not because of the lifestyle,
but because of what it could
do for you in your
career, and because you
were helping your country.
SPEAKER: I see.
What surprised you
most in the research,
or do you find conflicting
information that you
had to really think about?
ERIK LARSON: Well, what
surprised me most--
I mean, everything surprised me.
I mean Room 40, the whole deal.
But I think, actually, one of
the first and earliest things
to really surprise me was
just the fact that I had been,
personally, I had shared a
vast misconception, which
was that the Lusitania
was the World War I
equivalent of Pearl Harbor.
And that no sooner was the ship
sunk, than, boom were at war.
And that is not what happened.
As I was doing the
research for this book,
I would ask friends
and family who
knew what I was working on--
and that's not a lot of people,
because I generally
keep it pretty quiet,
what I'm working on.
But I would ask
them, I would say,
so how long do you think
it was between when
the ship got torpedoed and
when we got into World War I?
And the estimates ranged
from two days to two months.
Two days to two months.
But in fact, it
was two full years.
And not only two full years, but
when President Wilson finally
asked Congress for a declaration
of war-- or actually,
to be more precise, a
declaration that a state of war
already existed with Germany.
When he asked for
that from Congress,
he never once mentioned
the "Lusitania,"
because so many other things
had happened in the interim,
including the sinking of
actual American flag ships.
The "Lusitania," remember,
was a British ship
that happened to have
American passengers on board.
But between the time of
the sinking and the time
we got into the war, a number
of American ships were sunk.
And then, of course, there
was the infamous Zimmerman
telegram, which was the thing
that really finally flipped
the switch.
When Germany offered
Mexico an alliance,
and in return for
Mexico's participation,
Germany would do all it could
to help Mexico recoup New Mexico
and Texas.
Them's fighting
words for America.
And that's what really
got us into the war.
So that was a real
surprise to me.
I mean, again, it
goes back to what
you were taught in high school.
You know?
Boom.
Ship sinks, we're in the war.
That's all I knew.
That's all I knew before
I got into the story.
SPEAKER: I think that was
my perception as well.
Why don't we turn it over,
if anybody in the audience
has any questions.
ERIK LARSON: Yeah, sure.
You can ask me anything
except one question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK LARSON: That's
the question.
No.
You can't ask me
what I'm working on,
because I'm not
working on anything,
and it gets me very upset.
AUDIENCE: Could you
talk a little bit
about Churchill changing
the rules of engagement?
ERIK LARSON: Well,
it wasn't Churchill
who changed the
rules of engagement,
it was the German
Navy that changed
the rules of engagement.
Churchill was one of the early
doubters about the submarine.
And actually, there was a guy
in the Admiralty, Jacky Fisher,
who was Churchill's number two.
And he was one of
a couple of people
who foresaw the actual impact
of the submarine, which
was a very, very new thing.
And in a paper that
he wrote, he would
forecast that
submarines would be
used to sink ships without
warning, sink merchant ships,
and so forth.
Churchill rejected
that completely.
He thought, no, this is
too incredible to believe.
Nobody's going to do that.
So it was Germany that
changed the rules,
and it was the submarine
that was the fulcrum
for that change of rules.
And then one thing
led to another,
and everybody was
changing the rules.
AUDIENCE: I think there was
one rule that got changed,
which was the
firing over the bow,
and that that usually
would stop a ship.
ERIK LARSON: Well
that went out the door
before anybody even said boo.
I mean, that was one of
the old cruiser rules,
or the so-called
prize law rules.
The whole point of
those-- those rules
had been in place for
essentially 100 or more years,
governing how military ships
could engage civilian ships.
At all times, the crews and
passengers of those ships
had to be kept safe--
these are the old rules--
they had to be kept safe.
Passenger ships, you could not
even attack a passenger ship.
That was forbidden.
And those were the rules that
the submarine and the German
Navy essentially threw out
as of the spring of 1915.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And I'm collecting some
questions from the Livestream
here, we have one from
Hiram in the DC office.
There were apparently spies
on board during the sinking.
Was there any attempt to
capture or rescue them,
or any narrative
from their escapades?
ERIK LARSON: Yeah, there
were three German stowaways
aboard the ship.
Apparently, one had a camera.
And they were quickly
discovered by the crew,
and then they were
locked-- not in a brig,
the ship didn't have
a brig-- but they were
locked somewhere down below.
And to the best of
anybody's knowledge,
when the ship went down,
they were still locked below.
What they were doing
aboard, nobody knows.
There's speculation
that they were
looking for evidence that the
ship was carrying munitions.
It was.
That was not a secret,
as much as people might
like to think that it was.
So anyway, that's
the story of that.
AUDIENCE: How often does your
research for any of your books
involve new material?
And how often does
that new material
change the conventional
narratives?
ERIK LARSON: You know, in
every project that I do,
to a lesser or greater extent,
there is new material that I
come across.
And often a new perception
that I bring to it, because I'm
looking at it fresh.
In the case of the
"Lusitania," the new,
frankly, is the telling.
Although, there are a lot
of new bits in the book.
I mean, they're not going
to make newspaper headlines,
but they're there.
And I love coming across them.
But that was one of things that
made me a little bit hesitant
about doing a book
about the "Lusitania,"
was the fact that it had,
obviously, been done before.
But I did it best, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, I often
recommend your books
to my friends that think
they don't like nonfiction,
because they're so
engaging and so rich.
And earlier you said you
don't like the term narrative
nonfiction.
Can you explain that
a little bit more?
ERIK LARSON: Well, yeah, OK.
It's because, well first of
all, I just don't like labels.
I don't like labels.
For example, I think one of the
most awful labels that apply
to literature its chick lit.
You know?
Chick lit.
And I think any kind of
label distorts perception.
On the other hand, I don't know
what you'd call it otherwise,
except just maybe good
nonfiction storytelling.
So, it's my thing.
Other people call it
immersion journalism.
I hate that, although it's
very appropriate in terms
of a sinking ship.
And then the worst
of the worst, though,
is what was applied to Truman
Capote's book "In Cold Blood."
It's a great book.
Although nobody really knows
exactly how much of that
was real and how much not.
Because he never left
footnotes, and it was, whatever.
But that was referred to
by him, Capote himself
called it a nonfiction novel,
which is like, bizarre.
It's a novel, or it's not.
You know?
So I just don't like labels.
I don't like labels.
Thank you.
Keep recommending the books.
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Could
you talk about what
your process is like for
research, writing, and editing?
ERIK LARSON: Yeah, sure.
It's incredibly neurotic
and anal, really.
The research process, it begins
with parachuting into archives.
I mean, I love archives.
Every day is like
a detective story.
And the way you do it
these days, you go in,
you bring, of course--
nobody photocopies
anymore-- you bring
in a digital camera
and you photograph things.
My MO-- well, for this
book, my wife and I--
my wife was able to take a
sabbatical from her job--
and we based ourselves
in Paris for six months.
And so I could just take
the Chunnel to the UK.
I hate to fly.
So I could just take
the Chunnel, and go.
There's all these great
archives in the UK.
My MO is to go for about a
week, plunge into, let's say,
the National Archives
of the UK, at Kew.
Plunge in.
Photograph everything that
even looks remotely like it
might be useful.
I don't read the whole
thing while I'm there,
because that could take
months, and I don't
want to pay the hotel bills.
You know what I mean?
So I go in, I take,
you know, I mean I may,
by the end of the
week, I may have
1,500 photographs in my--
I'll fill up a memory card.
And then when I get back to my
home base-- or in this case,
it was Paris-- I
process all that stuff.
Print out the actual
images, and then read them.
And then when I'm done with
that, I go back for more.
And then finally, I end up with
stacks, and stacks, and stacks,
and stacks of documents,
sort of loosely
arranged by-- not typically
by content, but more
by my research
trip, because that's
how I'll remember them best.
And then everything
gets indexed and coded.
And then finally
I place everything
into a chronology,
which is essentially
an index to everything.
Because half the
battle is knowing
where your best stuff is.
I mean, if you have to,
at the end of the process,
find, like, a one word
fact that is terrific,
and you have to go through
20,000 pages of material
to find it, you'll go crazy.
You know?
But this chronology is
my index, but it's also
something else very valuable.
For this book it was 165 single
spaced pages on my computer.
And in the end, it served
as a de facto outline.
Because if you think about it,
one of the most powerful tools
in storytelling-- the most
powerful tool, as far as I'm
concerned-- is chronology.
Beginning, middle, and end.
So it becomes a
de facto outline,
and where things
clump together, I
know that that's likely
going to be a chapter.
And then during-- as
the action accelerates,
this chronology goes
from-- it might start just
with things sorted by
year, then by month,
it goes down to the
day, to the hour,
to the minute, in some
cases, in this chronology.
And that's a very powerful tool
for finding things, and also
knowing where you're going
to go as you write the thing.
That's a broad survey
of how I do it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ERIK LARSON: There's
a lot more to it,
but I don't want
to bore anybody.
AUDIENCE: The books
you've written
have had such
varied storytelling,
and I'm wondering if you've
had a subject that you've most
enjoyed researching, or a story
you've most enjoyed telling.
And I'm also wondering
what you're reading now,
and if you would recommend it.
ERIK LARSON: Oh, OK.
Well, you know, what
I'm reading now,
I'm reading-- I'll knock
off the easy one first.
That is-- first of all,
when I read for pleasure,
I read fiction.
Because I read so
much awful, frankly,
nonfiction in the
course of my day.
And I'm very grateful
that so much of it
is awful, because it
leaves a lot of room
to write something
that's decent.
You know?
But I read mostly fiction.
I love-- I've been, of
late, on a jag reading
dark Scandinavian
detective novels.
I love them.
You know, Henning
Mankell, Jo Nesbo.
And I'm rereading "Smilla's
Sense of Snow", by Peter Hoeg,
I think is how you pronounce it.
And then your other question
was, has there-- Repeat
the other question.
AUDIENCE: I wondered if
there was a subject that you,
of the books you've written, the
subject that you most enjoyed
researching or telling.
ERIK LARSON: Boy.
You know, it's really hard.
I love them all.
They all have
different challenges.
I mean, in some ways,
this particular book
was the most satisfying,
again, because
of this incredible
reservoir of material that I
was able to tap, it
was just so much fun.
And offered such a
tremendous opportunity
to really make this book into
kind of a nonfiction maritime
thriller.
I just love that.
However, there were elements
of some of my other books.
I mean, I loved the
World's Fair part
of "Devil in the White City".
I mean, it was just
like an endless treat.
But probably my all-time
favorite, frankly,
was in my book
"Thunderstruck", about Marconi
and the intersection
of his career
with Britain's second
most famous murder,
Hawley Harvey Crippen.
Second most famous, of
course, after Jack the Ripper.
Even though he really
only killed one person,
Crippen, but their
lives intersected
in a very funky way.
But what I loved
most was writing
the chase that occupies the
last 100 pages of that book.
Because I got so
lucky in the research.
Again, I went back to the
National Archives of the UK.
And really, literally, on
my last day of research.
And in that case, I had
not based myself in Europe.
I was living in Seattle.
To me, it was a torment.
11 hours each way by plane.
It was just a nightmare.
Xanax helps a lot,
let me tell you.
But there had been this file
that I was trying to locate.
And it was like, MePo
'98, or whatever it was.
Meaning Metropolitan
Police, '98.
I think it was '98.
And it was always eluding me.
It was always, every
time I asked for it,
it seemed to be out in
somebody else's possession.
And I thought, oh my
god, somebody else
is doing this book.
What is happening here?
And finally, out
of desperation, I
went up to the archive
information people,
and I said, look, I'm trying
to track this thing down.
Can you tell me where it is?
Is somebody using it?
I have to leave tomorrow,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And the guy says, oh,
yeah, it's in conservation.
So, OK.
So it's in the
part of the archive
where they work on their
files and conserve them,
so that they last
longer, and so forth.
And I said, well, can I see it?
He said, well, sure.
And so they let me see it.
I go through
successive-- I mean,
honestly, it was like some
kind of-- the security
to get to the conservation
room in the archives of the UK,
it was incredible.
It was like going
through airlocks.
You know?
Door, door, readers
guard, this, this, this.
And then, it was
like this moment,
where I sort of expected
to have some sort
of operatic crescendo.
And here, here on this
table, just there.
As soon as I opened
it, it was like I
had this-- it was like
an electric charge
went through me.
Right on the cover.
Right on the top of this huge
pile of materials in this file,
was this photograph.
Gleaming, classic, old high
silver-content photograph.
Just terrific photograph
of the detective
and his guys, after they
just dug up Crippen's wife.
And they just had
this-- there's a term
I would use to describe it.
But it's a certain kind
of grin that we all know.
And I'm not going
to use the term.
They were just so
smug and happy.
And then the rest of the
file, detail, after detail,
after detail, from
within Scotland Yard.
About this guy, and the
chase, and the investigation.
I couldn't believe it.
And of course, the last day.
So I just went down
the main office.
And I said, look,
I've got this thing.
This is where you arrange
to have things duplicated.
And I said, I don't care what
it costs, I want the whole file.
You know?
It was one of those
liberating moments.
I knew it was going to
cost me, like $1,000.
You know?
But I was going to
get that damn file.
And then sure enough, two
weeks later, by FedEx,
I get this whole thing.
It was like incredible.
I just love moments like that.
And so often, frankly, the best
stuff turns up on the last day.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIK LARSON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: In many
of your works you'll
explore larger
than life figures,
like Wilson and Churchill.
And explore nuances
and even weaknesses
behind these characteristics.
For this reason, have you
received any negative feedback
for these explorations?
Is there anyone
you wouldn't touch?
Or any events you wouldn't
touch as a consequence?
ERIK LARSON: No, there's
nothing I wouldn't touch.
I love conflict.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no, I mean, I love nuance.
I don't believe in heroes.
When I read anything
that contains
a saga of an unalloyed
hero, I wonder, OK,
what are you not telling me?
Because people are people.
You know?
I mean, Churchill,
he was essentially
fired from the Admiralty during
World War I, for the carnage
in the Dardanelles.
And then redeemed himself
again in World War II.
But nuance, I think,
is everything.
I mean, Wilson-- during
this period, context, again,
is everything.
He was head over heels in love
with his girlfriend-- well, not
yet his girlfriend.
She was holding
him at bay, and he
was writing these incredible
passionate love letters to her.
And I came across that, and I
was just like, I don't care.
These are going in the book,
whether they should or not.
This is too good.
And the fact that he was doing
this during the crossing.
As the ship was crossing, he was
writing these passionate love
letters.
I was like, wow.
It just seemed to fit.
So, there are those who
are annoyed at Wilson--
they're not annoyed at me,
they're annoyed at Wilson.
But the best example, though,
of this kind of thing,
was when I did a book
called "Isaac's Storm",
about a giant hurricane that
destroyed the city of Galveston
in the year 1900.
About the weatherman who
thought he knew everything
about the weather, but was
proven drastically, tragically,
wrong that day.
A guy named Isaac Cline.
Until this point, Isaac
Cline had been a Texas hero.
You know?
Like, he might as well
frankly have been,
you know, at whatever it was.
San Antonio-- you know, the
thing that the Texans always
talk about.
The Alamo.
He might as well have
been there, you know.
He might have been there in
the Alamo, for all I know,
but he should have been,
for how they viewed him.
But the fact is, he blew it.
He blew it that day.
And to tell the story in
any other way, is to lie.
Well, the Texans
did not like that.
A certain cadre did not like it,
to the point where at one talk
I gave, it at a large
bookstore in Bexar County,
I had to have a
Sheriff's deputy present.
Whether he was really
necessary, I don't know.
But anyway, so that's that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if you
have any advice for aspiring
writers.
Some time ago I
learned of an incident
that happened in World War
II, that just really struck me
as, oh my gosh, this is
just a fabulous story.
And I went and did a
little bit of research.
And someone actually has
already written a book
about it, a very small one.
But I don't think
a lot of people
know about this
particular incident,
unless they happen
to be around there.
So, it's something
that is certainly
in the historical record, but--
ERIK LARSON: What was the idea?
AUDIENCE: Uh, the idea--
[LAUGHTER]
ERIK LARSON: No,
no, no I'm kidding.
Don't tell me.
AUDIENCE: We'll talk
about it offline.
ERIK LARSON: Don't
tell me, don't tell me.
So what--
AUDIENCE: As far as
doing something that
perhaps has been done before.
ERIK LARSON: Well, first of all,
never be put off by something
that's been done before.
Because you are
approaching it in a way
that is invariably going to
be fresh, because it's you,
and not somebody else.
Right?
I mean, look at the
number of biographies
that had been done on Wilson.
Look at the number of
biographies that have
been done on Teddy Roosevelt.
You know?
I mean, it's been done.
But they're doing it
again, because they
feel that there's some way that
they're adding to the story.
That they're making it better.
Something is happening that
you're bring to the party.
So you have to have that
confidence to begin with.
The fact that somebody
already did a small book,
well, all right, so
that's one of the books
that you use for your research.
You know, you put that
in the bibliography.
Then you go ahead and do
yours, and you find, hopefully,
more stuff.
But the most important thing
is to find the stuff first.
You can't fake it.
You can't-- no
offense to Google--
but you can't just
Google things.
You've got to go to the
scene of crime, if you will.
You will find things
that you wouldn't not
find through targeted search.
You need to be there.
You need to touch things.
You need to find
those secret troves
of materials and documents.
Because, you know, what
this other guy got,
there may be 10 times as much.
He may simply have not found it.
He may not have gone to the
archives to look for it.
He may be hiding things.
I, mean you never know.
So that should never
be an obstacle.
I mean, if I had used--
now that, as I said,
that bothered me a bit
about the "Lusitania,"
was the fact that
others had done it.
But then once I
realized, you know, I
could bring something
new to this picnic,
I felt free to do so.
So I wouldn't use that obstacle.
But, the bottom
line is just do it.
Writing isn't going to
happen unless you do it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the reaction in Germany
after the sinking, and
then the change in the way
that the U-boats would
engage with ships.
From restricted, to
unrestricted, and back again.
Did that fundamentally
alter the course of the war?
Did that--
ERIK LARSON: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, what
happened in Germany, I
found to be very
interesting, was
that in the German hierarchies,
civilian and military,
there was actually a
division of opinion.
The civilian
leadership did not want
the Navy to continue
submarine warfare
against civilian
shipping, for fear
that America would
come into the war.
However, the German Naval
commanders eventually
gained ascendancy
with Kaiser Wilhelm,
persuading him through this
amazingly detailed plan,
this sort of methodical
German thinking,
that if they, instead, went
to completely unrestricted
warfare, that they could
bring Britain to her knees
within five months.
Had to start on
February 1, 1915,
but they could bring Britain
to her knees in five months,
exactly.
They had the timetable.
They had the whole
thing worked out.
And this persuaded Kaiser
Wilhelm to say, yes, OK, good.
We're going to go totally
unrestricted warfare.
And this, again, is in 1917.
And this is, in fact, what
got America into the war.
The civilian
leadership's worst fears
were realized when they started
sinking American flag ships.
Including one that carried
a mother and daughter
whom Wilson's girlfriend
knew well from Chicago.
And they were killed in
one of these sinkings.
So that was a material
change in German strategy,
and it's the thing that
really cost them the war.
What was the other
part of your question?
AUDIENCE: No, that was it.
ERIK LARSON: That was it.
OK, good.
SPEAKER: One last one,
Erik, if you don't mind.
ERIK LARSON: Yes.
SPEAKER: Over the course of
your career as an author,
or over the course
of writing this book,
how have you changed?
ERIK LARSON: I haven't
been asked that question.
I think I'm a happier person.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Really?
ERIK LARSON: No,
how have I changed?
I'm much more confident
about the whole process,
and about certain instinctive
things that now come to me more
naturally than did.
For example, knowing when
I have enough research.
Knowing when the time has
come to start writing.
I've got a good instinctive
sense of that now.
And also knowing when an idea,
once I have settled on an idea,
knowing when it's going to work.
What it what it needs.
What elements have to be there.
And before, I tried to
talk myself out of it.
But now I know.
I have a real sense of that.
And also, what else
has changed, is
that it has helped me put
my kids through college,
and I don't have to
worry about that anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Well, Erik,
I think we're at time.
Thanks so much for being here.
That was wonderful.
ERIK LARSON: Pleasure.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
ERIK LARSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]